the experience of playing halo infinite
is joyful and what more can you ask for
when it comes to a free-to-play online
multiplayer shooter and that's not to
say that halo infinite is without flaws
but 343 industry has stuck the landing
on what matters the most as halo
infinite feels
great it's a beautiful day
[Music]
what did i tell you about being funny
keep doing it
correct similar to halo 4 and halo 5
guardians the narrative basis for halo
infinite's multiplayer is a spartan
training program with both master chief
and the unsc infinity marked as missing
in action and the threat of cortana
still at large you join a team of
spartans at a secure facility and
prepare for the coming fight the
multiplayer feels like old school halo
but tweaked to better fit the modern fps
player base that has fallen in love with
shooters that accentuate their solid gun
play with smooth movement and quick to
deploy abilities halo infinite leans
into the traditional rhythm of the
series firefights it's a dance that will
feel familiar to long time fans but it
also now feels unique in today's shooter
climate with the longer time to kill
rate each spartan's rechargeable shield
divides combat into two distinct parts
while shielded you can take more risks
and utilize weapons that take longer to
have an immediate payoff but when that
shield is gone you're vulnerable and the
need to take more evasive maneuvers or
pull out a faster hitting weapon
increases if you can last long enough
your shield will recharge reverting you
back to the first phase as all players
are tied to these constraints fights are
typically less about what weapon you
have and more about how you choose to
use it halo has consistently been a game
of skill that rewards players for
fighting intelligently and knowing how
to best defeat an opponent and halo
infinite sticks to that trend equipment
complements the gun gunplay with every
piece of equipment being useful in some
way and most being useful in different
ways from mode to mode brief cooldowns
limited uses and the need to collect
them keeps each piece of equipment from
being spammed ensuring skilled use of
firearms remains the key component to
halo's end match meta halo infinite's
movement mechanics pair well with the
game's firearms and equipment
encouraging fast and aggressive play the
slide in halo infinite feels especially
good it's as essential to combat as
strafing or jumping when it comes to
avoiding shots and can be used to swing
around a corner and surprise your
opponent
of the new school shooter mechanics that
make their way into halo infinite the
ping system is the only one to really
fall short halo's core formula wasn't
built with a ping system in mind and
halo infinite isn't restructured to
address that fact the ping itself isn't
very informative though it thankfully
does tell squadmates how many enemies
are at a location it doesn't provide
context when pinging a place on the map
that can make it tricky to discern
whether a teammate is saying to look at
a spot defend a spot or attack a spot
putting the ping on the d-pad on a
controller also makes it hard to use the
mechanic in the midst of a fight given
how many objective-based modes are in
halo infinite a ping system is a smart
idea for helping teams coordinate their
efforts however the existing system
isn't all that helpful or easy to use
and since so few people use it players
aren't conditioned to take heat of it
and largely ignore it when their allies
do happen to use it when you're ready to
fight there are four available playlists
and halo infinite's multiplayer bot
bootcamp posts an assortment of 4v4
modes but set in a pve setting allowing
new faces to test and improve their
skills prior to diving into online
matchmaking quick play and big team
battle are halo infinite's two casual
online multiplayer playlists the first
includes the game's assortment of 4v4
game types while the second is 12v12 and
finally ranked arena presents
competitive variations of what's found
in quickplay pushing you to go up
against similar skilled players and
attempts to rise in rank as halo
infinite's multiplayer has launched an
open beta not all modes are live in the
game elimination for example is absent
at launch halo infinite has 7 modes save
for slayer all the modes in halo
infinite are objective base where
securing the most kills isn't the goal
for winning the game the challenge of
how to achieve these objectives adjust
to which map you're playing on which is
dependent on which playlist you're
queuing into bot bootcamp quickplay and
ranked arena feature smaller maps most
of which incorporate twisting corridors
that prioritize remaining hyper-aware of
your immediate surroundings and staying
ready to pop off in an intense fire
fight
double kill big team battle takes place
on significantly larger maps all of
which encourage smart player rotation
being a good shot is still important but
knowing how to most efficiently get from
point a to point b is even more critical
as you can be spawned a long sprint away
from the objective that needs you it's
an altogether solid library of maps
there are a few that annoy me whenever
they pop up notably high power because
of how unfairly overpowered the wasp is
on that map and behemoth because its
wide open layout and inclusion of
vehicles isn't a great fit for the 4v4
playlists overall though halo infinite
has kicked off with a welcome diversity
of fun arenas bizarre and recharge are
my two favorites featuring prominent
open middle spaces for those brave
enough for a hectic shootout while the
outer rims of both maps encompass
multiple levels of hallways and rooms
for those looking for a longer but
typically safer trip around the map
fragmentation is also really fun you
can't go wrong with a halo map that's
two bases sitting across from one
another and a long canyon halo infinite
also builds on the series collection of
firearms adding an assortment of new
guns to obliterate melt zap and crush
your enemies to death the core formula
remains unchanged alien weapons vaporize
spartan shields while human firearms
tear through the unprotected fleshy bits
halo infinite's new weapons fit right in
most are designed with secondary effects
or fire modes that when strategically
used lead to satisfying results
the sound design for all the weapons is
superb even if you can't see an enemy
you can immediately identify what weapon
they're using based on the sound it's
making this helps ensure the outcomes of
firefights lean towards skill as opposed
to luck in the few seconds that a fight
lasts visual and auditory cues can tune
you into what your foe is using against
you informing how you can respond to
beat them deaths of comedic misfortune
still happen this is still halo but they
aren't what you'll usually endure for
the most part the better player will
come out on top but again save for
slayer getting kills isn't usually the
most important goal for a match and even
if slayer is all you want you're
currently out of luck there are no game
type specific playlists in halo infinite
at launch instead 343 industries has
checked halo infinite's assortment of
modes and maps into each of its four
multiplayer playlists and you're
randomly thrown into one mode depending
on which playlist you pick beyond going
into custom games and making your own
playlists there's currently no way to
curate what you specifically want to
look for beyond whether you want to play
4v4 12v12 or 4v4 ranked i can certainly
see the appeal of it without this format
i doubt my friends and i would have
regularly played or even tried many
modes beyond slayer but as it happens
we've come to really like infinite's
oddball capture the flag one flat
capture the flack total control and
strongholds modes this current playlist
format ensures that every player gets a
healthy dose of every mode if you've
never touched halo in your life infinite
is a continuous sample platter to give
you a taste of what's on offer helping
you find new favorites to enjoy there is
a downside to this though you'll notice
i didn't mention that i enjoy stockpile
that's because i don't like stockpile i
don't want to keep playing stockpile
it's essentially a much slower variation
of capture the flag and with teams
needing to capture 5 batteries to win
around it can feel like matches are
going on for way too long halo infinite
is just a better game when players are
running around and shooting not slowly
walking around with glowing batteries
and being shot to death in seconds but
there's no option to filter out
stockpile so though it has its merits
and encouraging players to try multiple
game modes halo infinite's lack of
playlist curation ultimately means that
you'll occasionally be put into modes
that you may not want to play that can
be frustrating especially if you don't
have too much time in your schedule and
just want to play what you want to play
it really doesn't help that in-game
progression is also entirely tied to
completing daily and weekly challenges
and several weekly challenges are tied
to playing specific modes so when you
queue in hopes of getting a match in the
mode you need you might at first be put
into numerous modes you don't need to
play it's very frustrating especially if
the matches you're playing in the
meantime aren't doing much towards your
in-game progression 343 industries has
at least added a repeatable daily
challenge where completing a match earns
you some xp so no match is a total wash
but given that the daily challenge's
reward is so small progression is still
largely tied to weekly challenges where
rewards are more substantial so as fun
as halo infinite is to play skillfully
playing objectives and just being a good
teammate isn't rewarded through the
progression system as it stands it's
incredibly tedious to earn anything in
halo infinite short of dropping real
world money and buying battle pass
levels or cosmetics from the in-game
store not an especially compelling
solution despite these issues however i
keep coming back to the fact that halo
infinite is just fun to play with or
without those rewards
halo infinite's online multiplayer takes
everything that is good about halo and
amplifies it with the faster pacing and
abilities of more modern day shooters
not every new mechanic and feature fits
halo's established formula the ping
system isn't very informative and tying
all in-game progression to daily and
weekly challenges leads to an
unrewarding system but the sound design
is spot on most of the maps are
thoughtfully designed weapons hit with a
gratifying kinetic energy and the game
rewards skill even if it's still an open
beta halo infinite's multiplayer is
already a great to play shooter
[Applause]
[Applause]
perfect